hey guys today it is the 21st of July my
name is Jess McDonald and you're
watching gamespot news first up this
week's lot of free DLC for the witcher 3
has been revealed and luckily for us
unlike last week it's not a patch that
stuff's of the frame rate this week
you'll get new finishing animations for
guralt that shows his enemies what for
in new ways offending your enemies lives
in style is your jam then this should be
right up your alley the new finishing
moves will be available on all platforms
later this week previously released free
DLC for the witcher 3 has included
alternate costumes hairstyles and horse
armor project cars released in May of
this year was supposed to make its way
to the wii u eventually although now it
appears that eventually has become not
at all developer slightly mad studios
confirmed that the wii u edition of the
game was officially canceled explaining
despite much perseverance under wii
version of project cars we will no
longer be actively pursuing development
on it as the quality does not make our
own high standards nor our intended
vision for the title on this platform
creative director and each shooter added
that the game turned out to be simply
too much for wii u and that the studio
had no desire to release a product that
isn't at the very least comparable with
our highest-rated versions on other
platforms project cars is available on
PC Xbox one and ps4 finally the latest
issue of edge magazine is cast and light
on what we can expect from Dark Souls 3
Dark Souls 3 will feature both familiar
and new combat mechanics some of which
echo those in From Software's wildly
successful blood-borne Dark Souls 3
combat will feature a new ready sin
which can be activated to give players
an alternate combat style and of course
available attacks in this mode will vary
between weapons Dark Souls 3 is also set
to feature a faster and more useful back
step which was a popular blood-borne
edition alongside faster ranged weapons
reminiscent of blood bourn's quick to
fly a fire
weapons let me know down in the comments
if you think slightly mad made the right
decision with project cars you can hedge
against what we've got news on star
citizen concerns and then update for
Knights of the Old Republic too that's
everything I wanted to tell you about
today be sure to leave me your thoughts
and feelings in that comment box and
I'll catch you again tomorrow